things are getting pretty lonely for
president biden in his own party
according to politico democrats are
worried biden's scary poll numbers will
lead to a midterm bloodbath and some are
making sure to distance themselves from
the commander-in-chief like vulnerable
house democrat jared golden who says
he's not worried about biden's sinking
numbers and here's why quote what i know
about his approval ratings right now
versus my own is that i'm outpacing him
by about 30 points
uh harold for democrats they better hang
together or they will all hang
separately at the midterms
i think you're right i'd say two things
um there need to be some personnel
changes um
at the top of this oh boy you better
take my predictions i'm not gonna take
your prediction but i think i think
they've gotta look at
number one you don't you don't try to
tell the public what they should be
thinking and how they're living and what
they're experiencing their communities i
don't care if you're a democrat or
republican you do that at your own peril
you generally lose a race you meet
people where they are and if you want to
take them to another place you first got
to meet them you got to explain what
your plan is and and how and why your
vision is better than their their
opponents
right now the opponent democrats have
really is just
a nun by none democrat uh vision if you
look at the most recent polling from the
journal people are disappointed with
what we think are the priorities for the
country our priorities have to match
what everyday americans are thinking
would it be what they're buying at the
grocery store what they're buying at the
pump the gas station
be what their kids are learning in
school
we can still win this thing it's 11
months away i think about what we were
11 months ago today we're obviously in a
very very different place now a lot will
have to change i would focus on the
border i would focus on the economy and
i would focus on covit you focus on
those three things and you put the
personnel around you that can help you
do those things you got to fight against
you add crime to that because it's
there's no federal response on crime
there's there's no doubt about some of
the things i talked about in the last
segment that just really was a summary
of some of the things were around the
table i would figure out ways to help
mayors with mental health and with which
with getting police officers back on the
street but we just saw in the a block
with uncle larry kresner in philadelphia
he he spent all this whole press
conference saying we don't have a
problem there's nothing happening here
you don't believe your own eyes the
murders are not up crime is not up and
so it feels like they are
really disconnected and there's no real
cohesiveness from the top so he should
feel their pain instead of trying to
spin their pain he can't say oh
everything's great in this country
country doesn't think everything is
great the country feels like this
country is going down down down and
that's where he looks like he's at a
touch if i were a democrat running for
reelection you know what i'd do dana
what i would retire
i would go become a lobbyist and i'd
golf all day because why do i want to
sit around and dial for dollars if i'm
gonna get smoked in the midterms the
donors don't want to give me anything
right they know i'm getting smoked right
so i mean if what if i'm gonna run for
reelection i want joe biden to come take
a picture with me i don't want a photo
with joe i'd have mayor pete take a
picture with me i'd have michelle come
over and take a pic but i mean biden
shows up crowd doesn't even show up
you forgot yeah get me barack but that's
the point so
he's not barack barack was black he was
historic all right trump he's not trump
trump was historic they both had huge
bases and both of those guys parties got
crushed in the midterms what does joe
have going for him he's got nothing he's
got no charisma and the fundamentals of
the country are off with the supply
chains inflation the high crime the high
gas prices the open border this is a
funeral landscape for the party in power
and i don't see how they're going to
spin their way out of it one thing katie
what you think about jared gold in this
congressman's quote about being 30
points ahead of biden is that if you're
a voter that's disgusted with biden it's
not like you're going to vote for
another democrat that distance
themselves from biden you look what
happened in virginia you'll vote for a
republican if you feel like that
republican meets you where you are well
to your question about hanging together
hanging separately it's hard for
democrats to hang together when there
are so many different factions in the
party and you've seen this play out with
bill back better and joe biden having a
really hard time getting that across the
finish line and when it comes to
democrats who are saying no i would like
to not retire and keep my job they're
looking at their own polling in the
issues that are affecting their voters
they're hearing directly from
constituents who are calling their
offices every single day about inflation
kristen sinema senator from arizona
democrat has talked about this a lot
she's been one of the people holding up
joe biden's agenda in the senate says
inflation's actually a real problem for
people in arizona and the administration
is not addressing it properly and so
they're looking at their own numbers and
trying to distance themselves from the
president and hoping that their votes
and the way that they interact with the
people calling their office will benefit
them during the midterms
there really was a big if you think
about last year they were screaming at
each other over defund the police after
the midterm saying that this absolutely
hurt us and then you just continue
through 2021 and you see more of it well
it's not just that but to his point
if you just
played the game of dominoes if you
tightened up the border
that would help law enforcement that
would help the cities that would help
the economy it's just one thing but when
you have
six or seven different versions of the
democratic party fighting over who's
going to get the best sound bite
nothing will ever get accomplished you
have to fix one real thing
not imaginary things not oh we're going
to have infrastructure in 10 years guys
to what town right right because we're
all moving
by the time you get infrastructure in
california we'll be in new la montana
with the seven the new show you know
because they don't
just give us one just one
fix the border and let the dominoes fall
come on joe come on joe is what tyra
says you better listen to tyrus all
right ahead fresh off the chaos in
afghanistan president biden and vladimir
putin facing off ahead of another
potential foreign policy crisis